yeah oh my god oh I'm dying I can I
can't even concentrate
I'm here with BuzzFeed I'm playing with
tiny cute kittens my day is made we
designed for Bell this ring that would
sit on her little finger the costume
designers saw that I had one which my
mom had given to me and she was like can
I design one for bail because Bell's
mother dies when she's really young my
mom was still alive and healthy and well
just as a side note anyway I was really
proud of the ring and thought it was so
beautiful that I asked if I can keep one
and they said okay you want to come down
is this a little - oh no you kind of
want to stay ok you go here you stay
there and you can come down here
[Music]
I just wanted to make sure that we
stayed true to the original
so when kevin kline was gonna make
maurice les kind of like the inventor
and he wasn't gonna have that as his
story anymore I was like before could we
use that for bail and so we made bail
this inventor who invents this washing
machine so that she can sit and read
while it's doing her washing this one's
chasing his own shadow literally this is
too much I would want her to know that
she is a force to be reckoned with and
never to underestimate her own power
sometimes particularly young girls feel
like their voice doesn't matter and what
they have to say it doesn't really
matter and I think I would want her to
know that it does
[Music]
so many times when people have told me
that I can't do something it's gonna be
too hard or whatever else I try to use
that as motivation sometimes someone
telling you that you won't be able to do
something I'm like oh you don't know
what you just did in my imagining she
opens the library that's in the castle
and she turns it into a school and a
public library which she runs I love
that all of these guys are crazy and
this one is just chill yes they share
their love of books come Ionian Belle
are like perfect head and heart girls
they have both they're super smart but
they also have this incredible empathy
and compassion and ability to see kind
of beyond things and be non-judgmental
[Music]
we completed the final dance at the end
of the movie I had the sound guys
playing happy and Kevin Kline started
doing the conga and like everyone joined
in it was the most surreal thing I've
ever seen everyone in costume and the
beauty newbies or the conga
we think that we live in a post feminist
society so we're told you don't need
feminism anymore that we have the vote
that like we're all good and I think
actually that's incredibly disconcerting
because then when young women move into
the world and they realize oh why am I
not being paid the same why am I being
treated differently and they start to
blame themselves because they don't
understand that they're part of a
historic pattern they're part of a much
larger system which is kind of working a
little bit against them um no they never
want to leave I only want to be
interviewed by BuzzFeed from now on I'm
really gonna struggle to say goodbye to
this guy massive shout-out to Best
Friends Animal Society who save hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of kittens
they make sure that these guys find a
home she's been the highlight of my
press tour without a doubt we're peaking
right now there's nothing that's good